- Look at that.
(audience applauding)
- [Jay] Very nice.
- Thank you, Jay.
I went Christmas for you, today.
- I can see you look like a
baked potato wrapped in foil.
(Kristin laughing)
- That was funny.
- No, that's cute.
And the boots that go with it, very nice.
- I mean, you know what?
Here's to the women out there,
you don't always have to spend a fortune.
These are Steve Madden.
I know you don't care,
and I'm glad you don't know the brand.
But these were not expensive.
- No, and I have to say.
You are right on both counts.
I don't care and I don't
know the brand, yeah.
- And if we were dating,
I would be very relieved.
- If we were dating, I would
be in a lot of trouble.
So let's just leave it at that.
And I saw you sang with Kelly in New York
during a season premiere.
That's very cool.
(audience applauding)
- She picked a song, Jay
"On Top Of The World"
that hardly anybody would ever pick.
And it was really hot
for some reason that day.
And I showed up in three-inch heels
and she had her Converse on
and she's like, "We're
just gonna walk down."
And there was hot dogs sellers
and people taking our
pictures and we're singing.
She's like, "Just ignore them.
Just ignore them."
And we just had the best time.
I'm proud of her.
- Well, let me ask you this.
How excited are you that Broadway is back?
That's your life, that's
where you come from.
- Well, anything with a live
audience, Jay, and you know.
It's been like having you all here today.
(audience applauding)
- I saw her live show
at the Disney Theater
and it was really just an amazing shift
because there's so many tricks on TV.
You know, they add sound
and they mix things in,
but to see somebody with pure voice
just come out and sing.
It really was an amazing evening.
It really was.
- Thank you.
- I really enjoyed it,
I really enjoyed it.
Now, tell me about this.
You're gonna play Dolly
Parton in a musical?
- Well, I want to,
I'm lacking a couple things
and I think we both know what they are.
- I didn't say it.
- He didn't say it.
Now, she has said before
in the past several times
that she does see me as
someone who could play her,
and I just wanna say,
"Dolly, where's the camera?
Where's my camera?
Dolly, hurry up.
I'm ready."
- I think that would be, yeah.
I mean, you could obviously
have the voice for it.
Yeah, you can sing.
- I just grew up listening
to her and you know,
I do a pretty good, like I just,
♪ Here you come again ♪
That's my favorite.
- I'm thinking, I gotta go with "Jolene".
♪ Jolene, Jolene, Jolene ♪
I mean, come on, I can play Dolly.
(audience applauding)
- I remember seeing Dolly Parton,
nobody else would know
this, on candid camera
when she was very young.
- I remember Kenny.
- But Dolly Parton, she
was just a young girl,
but she would stand on the street corner.
"Could someone carry
me across this puddle?"
There's a puddle of water
and guys would come and pick her up
and carry her across them.
It was like the funniest.
You should ask her about that when you do.
I'm sure she's forgotten about it.
- She's so smart.
- Now, are you gonna
move to Nashville now?
Is that what I hear?
- Actually, I'm gonna
keep my place in New York.
I'll never not be a new
Yorker, Jay, but I am moving.
I've actually bought a place in Nashville.
I just wanna go.
I love it there.
You know, I just love it
there, it feels like home.
- We gotta talk about "The Voice"
because this is Kelly's show.
Now, you're an advisor on the show,
but you were working
against Kelly, is that true?
(booing)
- That is a fact.
I feel like I need to take
a shower now, thanks a lot.
Ariana Grande, I've known
since she was 10 years old
and she called and asked
if I would be her advisor
and we had been staying very close
and I said yes.
But besides Kelly's team,
I think Ariana's team is very good.
- Wow.
There you go.
(audience clapping)
Did you guys, you and Ariana
used to go on double dates?
Is that true?
- We had some, well, not as a couple,
which there's nothing wrong with that,
but no, with other partners.
Yeah, we had some dates, yeah.
- But not when she was 10.
- No.
Then I'd be in jail.
- That's right, you got to.
- But we just go and we like bowling.
We like truffle pizza
from Craig's here in LA.
Have you ever tried truffle pizza?
- [Jay] What kind of pizza?
- [Kristin] The truffle pizza.
- Okay. All right there, I don't care.
- [Kristin] Have you had it?
- No, I haven't.
In my family, I'd be beaten
if I had a truffle pizza.
It's like pineapple on a pizza.
- I agree.
But no, you're wrong on this.
Just, will you trust me?
Will you trust me, Jay?
- Cheap Italian food is the best in time.
Why do you put truffles on it
and some pig going (snorting) on my pizza?
No, it doesn't.
- [Kristin] It's yum.
- It's all right.
- You're missing out.
- Right. Now, what can we expect
on the new Christmas album?
Tell me about it.
- When I was thinking about,
'cause doesn't it feel
like Christmas was canceled
for like two years or something?
- [Jay] Yeah, it does.
- I was pretty down in the dumps
and not being able to perform live,
but doing other kinds of
work that I also enjoy,
but I like a live crowd.
And so.
(audience applauding)
- You were just booing her a minute ago.
What a bunch of hypocrites.
- What are you doing to them?
I was thinking about
the feel for the album
and I went to Nashville to record it
with some of the best musicians.
And we had partitions,
and we had our masks,
and I said, "It's we are light.
We are light for each other.
We see the light coming
at the end of the tunnel."
And I have Keb' Mo' on there doing,
"How Dare I Do a Blues Song?"
We're doing "Merry Christmas Baby".
A lot of songs y'all know.
And then a couple that aren't,
there's a song on there I co-wrote called
"Santa, I Got A Bone To Pick With You".
It's about the crappy presents
you get for Christmas.
- Really?
Well, that's I think the
real meaning of Christmas.
Complaining about the crappy gifts
that someone took a lot of
love and time just to look for.
- I mean, contacts, mismatched socks?
It happened to me.
- Now you have a song and this one.
Was it "Why Can't Christmas?"
- "Why Can't It Be Christmas Every Day?"
"Why Can't It Be Christmas
Every Freaking Day?"
- But that wouldn't work.
Then you need another holiday.
You need super Christmas.
It's like champagne.
If you drink it every
day, you're an alcoholic.
You know, it's like a special occasion.
- You telling me
you'd be tired of
Christmas every single day,
getting presents and going
to see all your family.
- I'd be tired buying
presents every single day.
Guys, buy present.
Guys, is that pretty much what it is?
Thank you very much, thank you very much.
It's bad enough we got Valentine's Day.
Somehow the wool got pulled
over our eyes on that one,
middle of February I need to gift wife.
So no, Christmas every day
would be a nightmare, oh my God.
- A gift can be just
something like a smile.
(audience awwing)
- Guys, guys, I'll give
you props for that one.
A friend of mine for his
25th wedding anniversary
he told me, I said, "Well,
what did you get her?"
He said, "I got her a breadmaker."
I go, "Okay, first of all,
you don't give your wife a breadmaker.
Why don't you give her
a broom or a vacuum?"
He goes, "I think you're crazy."
And then she starts to
open it and she goes,
"Is this a joke?"
He goes, "Yeah, you're right.
You're like, you have to suck.
Luckily he thought fast.
It was late comments
so I got this as a gag
and he managed to avoid the bullet.
But then he said-
- In two days you get a new car.
- That's right, that's right.
And that's literally what it took.
So don't give me a smile, shut up.
Just a smile, yeah.
Now what holiday traditions
do you have back in Oklahoma?
- Well, we eat, and then we eat-
- [Jay] Really? Eating?
- And then we eat some more.
- There you go.
- And then we pray and then we eat.
And we pray about all
the food we've eaten.
(audience applauding)
- I mean, are there any sort
of real Oklahoma traditions
that you have?
- I mean, my dad, there's
a channel with one.
- [Jay] What is that?
- He always goes, "Now this year,
we're going to go around the table,
we're gonna tell everybody
what we're most grateful for."
I'm like, "Okay, you first."
Because he doesn't like to cry.
And so he'll go, "Well,
I'm most, excuse me."
I'm most (mumbling)
and I just liked to watch him suffer.
- Well, you really have
the spirit of Christmas.
Now speaking of Oklahoma,
I have to ask about this.
Tell me about this throwback
cheerleading photo.
Can we put that up there?
- [Kristin] Which one?
- Where is it?
There it is, there it is right there.
(audience applauding)
I got to ask,
how many 40-year-olds
are still in high school?
Look at that picture.
- I'm so upset by my hairdo.
And by the way, the
pompoms when I was young
were as big as me.
And I remember having to do
a tick check after that, Jay.
- [Jay] A tick check?
- Around the woods, my hair, my hair.
- I thought there was some
dead animal at your feet.
It looks like some dead zebra hybrid.
- No, you mean The Tigers?
- I mean, what is it about old?
Why do people look older in old photos?
- Because, are we not always
trying to look older y'all?
And then when you get to be about 30,
you're like, "Let's stop that train."
- But it's going too fast.
Oh my hair, let's never show that again.